bonjour bienvenue dans Parlement Hebdo
45 minutes pour faire ensemble le tour
de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire bonjour Michael
à la une cette semaine à la reculade du
gouvernement sur le projet de l'Oise
famille dans un premier temps la
procréation médicalement assistée était
écartée puis c'est au tour de la loi
dans sa totalité officiellement pour se
donner plus de temps colère des députés
de la majorité et de leurs alliés on y
reviendra dans moins de deux mois ce
sont les élections municipales la droite
de reconquête la gauche espère conserver
ses bastions les sondages se multiplient
nous en parlerons l'autre grand inconnu
c'est bien sûr l'abstention nous irons à
Montreuil ou des jeunes se mobilisent
enfin comme chaque semaine le plus de
l'hebdo vous propose un documentaire
cette semaine Giscard l'impossible
retour de Laurent luteau après sept ans
au pouvoir une défaite Valéry Giscard
d'Estaing passer 30 ans à tenter de
revenir sur le devant de la scène à
retrouver à la fin de l'émission
bonjour André Malini bonjour c'est
Nathan socialiste président du conseil
général de l'Isère vous êtes aussi
spécialiste de la justice mais vous êtes
aussi un fin connaisseur du territoire
français cette semaine vous avez accordé
une interview dans le monde avec un
titre en finir avec le jardin à la
française en clair comment faire des
économies dans tous ces territoires
comme on regrouper ces territoires
est-ce que vous diriez aujourd'hui que à
gauche on n'est pas tous d'accord en
tout cas vous n'êtes pas tous d'accord
sur le principe est accordé François
Hollande sur le regroupement de ces
territoires pour pouvoir faire des
économies
à gauche comme à droite il y a des bas
sur les territoires sur la
décentralisation sur la nécessité
d'économiser l'argent public c'est
toujours utile de rationaliser les
collectivités locales de les rendre plus
efficaces plus lisible par les citoyens
donc à gauche comme à droite il y a des
débats mais je crois que tout le monde
est d'accord maintenant parce que
nécessité fait loi tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire que il y a trop de
collectivités territoriales il y a trop
d'échelons dans le fameux mille-feuille
administratif il faut simplifier tout ça
est-ce que d'avoir fait notamment le
conseiller général le conseiller
régional c'est à l'époque de Nicolas
Sarkozy avait voulu faire ce conseiller
territorial François Hollande est revenu
sur cette loi est-ce que c'était une
erreur de revenir ou d'avoir fait le
conseiller territorial
non je pense que le conseiller
territorial était une fausse bonne idée
on l'a beaucoup diabolisé parfois un peu
à l'excès à gauche c'était une réforme
qui avait été imaginée par le comité
Balladur dont j'étais membre à l'époque
mais je pense que c'était une mauvaise
idée parce vous allez mélanger régions
départements qui n'ont pas la même
vocation qui n'ont pas du tout les mêmes
compétences il faut moins de régions des
régions beaucoup plus grandes beaucoup
plus puissantes économiquement bien sûr
mais aussi en termes de population de
superficie des grandes régions
françaises comme en Allemagne en Italie
ou en Espagne et puis concernant les
départements garder les départements en
milieu rural car ils sont utiles
ailleurs les fusionner voir les faire
disparaître lorsque des métropoles vont
monter en puissance et vont absorber les
économies bien sûr
de l'actualité politique alors le début
de la semaine a été marqué par les
débats sur la famille lundi le
gouvernement reportait la loi prévu au
printemps
un début de semaine donc marqué par les
débats sur la procréation médicalement
assistée et la loi famille une
manifestation dimanche dans un premier
temps le gouvernement exclut la PMA de
la loi famille puis c'est le projet de
loi lui-même qui est reporté cinédié
officiellement les travaux ne sont pas
terminés il faut se donner plus de temps
une reculade dénoncée par les députés de
la majorité Jean-Baptiste Daoulas
ce matin les députés socialistes
reviennent à l'Assemblée avec des
questions étonnées par le report de la
loi sur la famille pour moi je suis un
peu surpris je vous avoue de la décision
de retrait la loi d'autant que le
gouvernement avait annoncé depuis
longtemps que il ne comporterait ni la
GPN et la PMA donc il y a deux questions
quand et qu'est-ce qu'on aura dans ce
projet de loi famille pour de nombreuses
socialistes l'équation est compliquée
comment critiquer le recul sur la loi
famille sans pour autant gêner le
gouvernement je vais pas participer à
une réponse qui pourrait me fragiliser
si je commence à commenter on aurait pu
on perd du temps en réunion de groupe
les députés PS acceptent de temporiser
sur la PMA mais pas question d'enterrer
une loi sur la famille j'aurais pas
qu'on jette le bébé avec l'autre du bain
parce qu'on doit améliorer la situation
l'adoption dans le pays parce qu'on doit
pouvoir parler de la médiation familiale
au moment des divorces parce qu'on va
parler du statut des beaux-parents reste
à trouver une solution pour réformer au
plus vite l'adoption le statut du
beau-parent et la naissance sous X ça
peut être des propositions de loi ça
peut être un projet de loi c'est pas
encore arrêté mais nous tenons à ces
réformes plus question donc de repousser
une loi sur la famille il y a 2015 c'est
pourtant ce que Matignon annonçait hier
officiellement le Premier ministre est
satisfait de ce nouveau compromis le
gouvernement sera attentif à toutes les
propositions qui viendront des groupes
parlementaires pour avancer concrètement
pour améliorer la vie des Françaises et
des Français pour présenter une
proposition de loi les socialistes
devront trouver un créneau dans le
calendrier parlementaire d'après Claude
barthelen ce pourrait être après les
municipales André vallignait saint
renoncement du gouvernement après les
manifestations de dimanche
c'est un report ce n'est pas un
renoncement ce n'est pas une reculade
comme vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
c'est un report je crois que dans
l'opinion publique il y avait beaucoup
d'incompréhension par rapport à cette
loi famille est-ce qu'il y avait dedans
ou plutôt ce qu'il n'y avait pas dans la
loi family notamment la PMA la
procréation médicalement assistée il y a
eu de l'incompréhension dans l'opinion
publique il y a eu de la désinformation
aussi de la part de certains mouvements
qui ont manifesté qui ont dit des choses
qui ne sont pas vraies donc il fallait
calmer le jeu prendre un peu de recul
par rapport à tout ça et j'ajoute que
rien n'est enterré en tout cas pour ce
qui est de l'adoption du statut des
beaux-parents de l'accouchement sous-ic
de la médiation en cas de divorce toutes
ces réformes qui sont attendues par les
Français et qui font consensus vont
venir en discussion au Parlement au
printemps pour ce qui est de la PMA les
esprits ne sont pas encore suffisamment
murs il y avait même un désaccord entre
le gouvernement et une partie de sa
majorité donc il était sage de reporter
la discussion comment vous expliquer que
le lundi le Premier ministre dis on
reporte la loi qu'un petit peu plus tard
ils disent finalement les députés et
bien vous pouvez faire des amendements
vous pouvez faire des textes de doigts
et on va les examiner ça ressemble un
peu de la cacophonie c'est un jour oui
un jour non si vous voulez me faire dire
que la semaine n'a pas été formidable en
termes de communication politique de la
part du gouvernement et de la majorité
je vous l'accorde première non plus la
première semaine où ça se passe aussi
mal il y en a pas eu beaucoup
heureusement d'ailleurs mais l'essentiel
de regarder devant il va y avoir des
réformes consensuelles je le répète j'en
ai parlé à l'instant au printemps à
l'initiative des députés ce qui est un
peu curieux dans ce pays c'est que
lorsque les députés prennent des
initiatives se font entendre ne sont pas
toujours d'accord avec le gouvernement
et veulent absolument faire passer
quelques réformes consensuelles celle-ci
on dit mais c'est le désordre dans la
majorité s'ils ne disent rien s'ils sont
disciplinés on les traite de godillot il
faut savoir moi je pense que ce qui
s'est passé cette semaine on peut aussi
le positiver en disant que le
gouvernement a retiré la loi dont il
était à l'origine parce qu'il y avait de
l'incompréhension à cause de la PMA et
la rue
peut-être aussi à cause de la
manifestation dimanche je n'en suis pas
si sûr que ça mais parce que surtout il
y avait un problème entre le
gouvernement et sa majorité mais s'il y
a accord entre le gouvernement et sa
majorité sur les réformes consensuelles
dont j'ai parlé il faut les voter elles
seront voter au printemps est-ce que
cette proposition de loi par exemple des
députés ça serait finalement la sortie
de crise idéale pour le gouvernement
oui enfin il faut pas exagérer la crise
non plus il y a des choses plus
compliquées encore et je pense surtout à
la situation économique moi je pense que
aujourd'hui l'essentiel l'essentiel
c'est la situation économique du pays il
faut que toutes les énergies au
Gouvernement au Parlement soit mobilisés
pour redresser le pays sur le plan
économique le reste est important le
reste viendra aux temps utile mais
l'obsession des parlementaires notamment
socialistes ce doit être l'économie
c'est pas le cas en ce moment
cette semaine on n'a pas assez parlé du
pacte de responsabilité et un peu trop
de la loi famille et justement dans
votre majorité il y en a aussi qui râle
ce sont ce sont les Verts je vous
propose d'écouter Noël ma mère
non seulement le gouvernement a cédé à
la rue mais on peut il fait preuve d'une
très grande fragilité d'une très grande
faiblesse et il fragilise la démocratie
en donnant le sentiment que quand la rue
proteste il faut tout arrêter je pense
que nous ne sommes plus en mesure
politiquement d'aborder les réformes de
société parce que ce gouvernement a
apporté la preuve qu'il n'en a pas le
courage c'est un gouvernement de lâche
gouvernement de lâche juste aussi un
député qui est ma mère fait toujours
dans le dans le soft et là c'est un peu
c'est même très très excessif il faut il
faut savoir raison garder le
gouvernement après une bonne décision
l'opinion n'était pas prête à ce que
l'on discute de la PMA si les
parlementaires maintenant souhaitent et
ça va être le cas qu'on adopte des
réformes sur l'adoption les
beaux-parents l'accouchement sous X et
le divorce à l'amiable entre guillemets
ça sera fait ce sera très bien
parler du Comité national d'éthique il
faut attendre la vie du comité nationale
éthique à la fin de l'année au début de
l'année prochaine il y a un député qui a
dit cette semaine dans la salle des
quatre colonnes aussi que vous
connaissez bien l'Assemblée nationale je
vais lancer le courant la gauche morte
ça donne un peu le sentiment de moral
des troupes non
oui non mais chacun il va de sa petite
phrase pour qu'on parle de lui encore
que je pense que ce député préfère
garder l'anonymat il vaut mieux pour lui
d'ailleurs dans tout ça n'est pas très
important et totalement inutile il faut
être concentré sur l'obsession qui doit
être la nôtre celle des Français la
situation économique comment on fait
pour gouverner quand on est à 19 % des
sondages pour que ce qui est le cas de
François Hollande dans un sondage TNS
sauf reste 49% de bonnes opinions chez
les socialistes c'est très très peu
François Hollande a été élu en 2012 pour
redresser le pays non pas pour être
populaire tout au long du quinquennat
non pas pour avoir de bons sondages ce
serait tellement facile de faire de la
démagogie de tout lâcher de laisser
filer les déficits de d'augmenter la
dette bref de faire un peu ce qu'a fait
la droite pendant des années là il
serait peut-être plus populaire et
encore je n'en suis pas sûr aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que François Hollande a des
difficultés dans l'opinion publique
c'était attendu c'était prévisible il
faut avoir une espèce de fermeté
churchillienne face à ces sondages face
à ces mouvements de l'opinion en tenir
compte bien sûr être conscient du fait
que les Français ne sont pas contents
mais savoir que le cap est fixé et que
c'est le bon parce que c'est le seul cap
celui du redressement économique de la
compétitivité de l'industrie française
nous sommes en guerre économique
François Hollande sonné le tocs en
quelque sorte avec son pacte de
responsabilité il appelle un sursaut
national des parlementaires même de
droite moi j'ai beaucoup apprécié ce qui
a dit Jean-Pierre Raffarin ce qu'a dit
Bruno Le Maire ce qu'a dit François
Baroin lorsque François Hollande a
annoncé son pacte de responsabilité donc
même à droite il y a des gens
responsables il faut mobiliser les
forces politiques le patronat qui semble
se dérober un peu depuis quelques jours
et je suis un peu inquiet de l'attitude
de Monsieur patron
le Medef et Monsieur Gattaz devrait être
responsable ils ont voulu une baisse des
charges sociales elle est conséquente
elle est importante elle va leur être
accordée moyen des contreparties et il
faut qu'il joue le jeu maintenant les
syndicats aussi 50 milliards d'économies
d'économies au syndicat d'être
responsables aussi de jouer le jeu
la CFDT est parfaitement responsable
bien sûr je trouve que les autres
syndicats sont dans des postures un peu
trop classiques pour ne pas dire
archaïque il faut sonner la mobilisation
générale il faut un sursaut du pays pour
s'en sortir nous sommes en guerre nous
sommes menacés de déclin alors justement
dans moins de deux mois ce seront les
élections municipales à la politique
nationale va-t-elle jouer
l'une des grandes inconnues des
municipales ce sera donc l'abstention
les Français vont-ils se mobiliser pour
lutter contre l'abstention nous sommes
allés à Montreuil ou des jeunes
justement ont décidé de sensibiliser les
lycéens un reportage de Paul Bouffard
de la politique à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
je comprends rien j'ai pas envie de m'y
intéresser plus d'intérêt dans la
politique tonnaccio est le symbole de
cette jeunesse qui rejette nos élites
alors devant le lycée Jean Jaurès de
Montreuil ce sont des jeunes comme lui
qui tentent de combler le fossé tu vas
voter aux municipales
je pense et si j'ai bien compris c'est
pas à vous de venir à la politique
à la sortie des cours Jean-Luc et Émilie
battent le rappel leur objectif
réconcilier ces jeunes votants avec la
politique et leur citoyenneté
municipales européennes en 2014 il y
aura du travail pour les guider vers les
urnes de l'action de ce matin c'est pour
un peu voir le point de vue de tous les
jeunes sur le vote et essayer de
comprendre pourquoi certains jeunes qui
sont en âge de voté ne vont pas voter je
pense que les jeunes ont intérêt à aller
voter je pense que c'est primordial
parce que si personne est à l'initiative
comment on peut changer les choses ça
passe par le vote des personnes en
général mais surtout des jeunes qui se
sont concernés parce que c'est l'avenir
même constat pour Steve fovio alors on
se mobilise l'animateur connaît bien les
jeunes de la ville il l'observe la
courbe de l'abstention ici à Montreuil
suit l'envolée de la courbe nationale
pour lui l'esprit citoyen s'est éloigné
je pense que c'est l'histoire de l'offre
et de la demande aujourd'hui on a quand
même un problème d'offre de nos
politiques des partis traditionnels dans
lesquels dans les dans lesquels les
jeunes se reconnaissent pas forcément
notamment par rapport au programme et
aussi sur la représentation puisque
aujourd'hui quand même le paysage
politique en France est assez est assez
âgé donc aujourd'hui il y a pas
forcément beaucoup de jeunes qui se
reconnaissent dans les politiques une
défiance qui s'était déjà manifestée en
2008 aux dernières élections municipales
près d'un jeune sur de n'avait pas pris
par au vote bien sûr on va parler de
l'abstention et des municipales avec
notre zoom de la semaine
et avec nous pour en parler Frédéric
Davy bonjour bonjour directeur général
adjoint de l'institut Ifop vous avez
entendu dans ce reportage une sorte de
désaffection morale des troupes aussi
chez les jeunes mais pas vraiment envie
d'aller s'investir dans ces élections
municipales ça c'est quelque chose que
vous ressentez aussi dans vos sondages
oui ce n'est pas une surprise on sait
que les jeunes votre massivement pour
une élection un peu comme l'ensemble des
Français à l'élection présidentielle et
dans les premiers indicateurs de
participation qu'ils soient peut-être en
train de faire on a on aurait une
abstention qui serait équivalente à
celle des municipales de 2008 qui avait
été un record d'abstention alors que on
sait très bien que la figure du maire
est celle qui échappe le plus aux
discrédit qu'ils connaissent les
politiques et dans ce cadre là les
jeunes il y a un clivage générationnel
pour le dire très simplement plus on est
la plus on est âgé plus on va voter ce
sont les jeunes qui votent le moins
c'est grave docteur
c'est un signe de cette crise de la
représentation que l'on connaît et
maintenant il y a une sorte de schéma
qui s'est installé dans le paysage
électoral français les Français c'était
une surprise en 2012 vote massivement à
l'élection présidentielle comme ils
avaient voté massivement à l'élection
présidentielle de 2007 et qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé entre 2007 et 2012 à tous
les scrutins intermédiaires des records
d'action ont été dépassés aux
municipales de 2008 aux européennes de
2009 et aux autres scrutins on va voir
pour 2014
par l'action en faisant concrètement des
choses qui les intéressent qui leur
plaisent bien sûr qui sont culturelles
mais il n'y a pas que ça le sport
évidemment mais plus problème plus
sérieusement entre guillemets il faut
montrer aux jeunes que on peut sortir
leur ville en l'espèce de la situation
où elle se trouve que leur quartier
n'est pas voué à être un ghetto qu'on
peut en trouver des débouchés
professionnels les jeunes sont voilà ils
sont ils sont beaucoup plus lucides et
responsables que nous ne pouvions l'être
à leur âge et ils sont demandeurs
d'authenticité de vérité s'ils sentent
que l'on triche un peu avec eux c'est
fini d'offre des partis politiques
traditionnels comme le dit le médiateur
dans ce reportage
municipales j'espère que ça va être
mieux cette fois-ci mais les listes
municipales jusque là ne reflétaient pas
assez la réalité j'ai pas dit la
diversité la réalité de la société
française mais je crois que des efforts
sont faits à gauche comme à droite
d'ailleurs on essaie d'avoir des listes
municipales qui ressemblent à la
population
d'être dit lorsqu'on regarde l'offre
électorale actuelle il vraiment un
effort des parties politiques du PS de
l'UMP du Front national qui est forcé
parce qu'il n'a pas de cadre plus âgé à
avoir des têtes de liste très jeune la
tête de liste socialiste de Nantes à
peine 30 ans la tête de liste tu MP par
exemple de Tourcoing et extrêmement
jeune il y a vraiment par rapport à ce
que disait le médiateur il y a une offre
électorale qui commence à ressembler au
municipales à ce qu'est la population
alors sur un petit peu plus dans le
détail politique politique
l'abstention c'est l'ennemi de la gauche
pour ces élections c'est l'ennemi du
parti au pouvoir avant de regarder les
intentions de votre ville par ville il
faut regarder est-ce que les gens vont
aller voter et une élection municipale
c'est d'abord un différentiel de
participation un camp va voter plus que
l'autre en 2008 la gauche a pu voter que
la droite et là ce que l'on a dans nos
enquêtes indicateur il faut que JTD de
début janvier on a 10 points de moins de
mobilisation à droite par rapport à
gauche alors sachant que à gauche c'est
un petit peu il faut regarder
attentivement les sympathisants
socialistes veulent aller voter c'est
plutôt ceux qui sont aux ailes du
écologie où il y a une un doute quant à
l'utilité du vote tout ça est très vrai
dans les grandes villes où les villes
moyennes dans les villages et Dieu sait
s'ils sont nombreux sur France dans les
petites communes j'en ai beaucoup en
Isère j'ai 533 communes dont 500 sont
vraiment toutes petites les gens vont
beaucoup voter à fortiori quand il y a 2
listes parce que tout le village est
concerné mais là c'est pas politique du
tout c'est très personnel mais ça
mobilise électorat merci beaucoup
Frédéric baby pour cette éclairage alors
retour au Parlement le Sénat étudier
mardi une proposition de loi sur
l'accueil des mineurs étrangers isolés
les sénateurs veulent que l'État prenne
en charge le coût de l'accueil de ces
mineurs un coup jusque là assumé par les
départements les explications de Jérôme
Rabier
ils sont environ 8000 sur le territoire
national les mineurs isolés étrangers
sans tuteurs légales présents avec eux
sont aujourd'hui inexpulsables au nom de
la protection de l'enfance et ce sont
les départements qui en ont la charge
comme pour tout ce qui touche l'aide
sociale à l'enfance une situation
critiquée par quelques Présidents de
Conseils généraux dont les départements
seraient surchargés cela sont des
mineurs qui viennent par vague
successives et qui arrivent de
l'étranger donc c'est l'État qui ne
maîtrise pas les flux ni au départ ni à
l'arrivée et donc l'État doit assumer
ses responsabilités au niveau de ses
flux et doit l'assumer financièrement à
gauche on souligne qu'une circulaire
existe depuis un an pour les répartir
sur le territoire le rapporteur
préconise une simple discussion générale
en séance Mercredi prochain avant trois
rapports attendus sur le sujet au mois
d'avril mais il concède qu'il y a des
choses à modifier l'hébergement
définitif de ces mineurs doivent relever
du département par contre l'État doit
prendre intégralement en charge ce qu'il
ne fait pas aujourd'hui toute la phase
de diagnostic d'évaluation d'orientation
dont le secteur associatif on s'inquiète
de la distinction entre mineurs français
et étrangers alors qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui mélangés ce qui permet une
meilleure intégration en gros elle tend
à dire
c'est à l'état de prendre en charge
cette question et à traiter d'abord
cette question comme un problème
d'étranger présent sur le territoire et
non pas comme un problème relevant de la
convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant la proposition sera examinée en
commission des lois demain matin avant
une discussion en séance le 12 février
mais faute de majorité peu de chances
qu'elle soit adoptée
les misères étrangers c'est à peu près
8000 personnes sur notre territoire
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait on les traite
avec le plus d'humanité possible bien
sûr ce sont d'abord des êtres humains
jeunes mineurs en grande souffrance qui
la plupart du temps on fuit leur pays
ont fui la misère de leur pays parfois
la dictature donc il faut les traiter
avec beaucoup d'humanité mais sans
naïveté parce qu'on s'aperçoit et je le
vois en Isère on s'aperçoit que ces
jeunes sont souvent la plupart du temps
d'ailleurs pris en main par des réseaux
des passeurs qui leur prennent beaucoup
d'argent pour les faire passer par
bateau la Méditerranée quand il n'y a
pas naufrage et qui les amène en Europe
sans aucun débouché sans aucune
perspective d'intégration donc il faut
combattre ces réseaux avec la plus
grande fermeté pour ce qui est des
mineurs les traités avec humanité bien
sûr
savoir aussi s'ils sont mineurs parce
que on n'est pas toujours sûr qu'il le
soit donc il y a des tests qui sont qui
sont faits dans les hôpitaux on le fait
en disant qu'on est dans tous les
départements c'est un sujet très
compliqué qui coûte cher au département
qui n'ont pas les ressources qui
souhaiteraient avoir pour s'occuper de
toute action sociale
d'assumer le financement il faut qu'on
trouve un accord entre l'État et les
départements il faut que l'État
participe à cette action en direction
des mineurs étrangers isolés il ne peut
pas laisser cette compétence à la seule
charge des départements qui ont
tellement d'autres charges à assumer
avec des finances en grande difficultés
mais je pense qu'on va pouvoir trouver
un accord derrière cette question
derrière ce débat est-ce que c'est la
question de l'accueil des mineurs des
droits de l'enfant ou est-ce que c'est
la question des flux migratoires qui se
posent ce sont les deux dans cette dans
le problème qui est posé par les mineurs
étrangers il y a bien sûr
le fait qu'il soit mineur qu'on doit
protéger ses mineurs ce sont des enfants
mais ils sont étrangers donc c'est aussi
à l'état de jouer son rôle on est au
carrefour
de deux politiques la politique de
l'enfance qui relève des départements et
la politique migratoire qui relève de
l'État c'est pour ça qu'il faut trouver
un accord vous voyez aussi d'intégration
la semaine prochaine de Premier ministre
va remettre le dossier sur la table si
on peut dire normalement il devrait y
avoir la formation d'un
Haut-Commissariat Manuel Valls disait en
décembre dernier l'intégration est un
échec en France
qui peut dire le contraire quand on voit
la ghettoïsation de certains quartiers
quand on voit le taux de chômage des
jeunes issus de l'immigration quand on
voit ce qui se passe dans certaines
banlieues et et justement c'est jeunes
qui sont en déshérence totale
il est évident que l'intégration n'a pas
marché que depuis 25 ans les
gouvernements successifs n'ont pas fait
les efforts suffisants pour lutter
contre la ghettoïsation et pour donner
une formation professionnelle assez
jeune donc il faut évidemment reprendre
cette politique oui pas explosif
compliqué parce que c'est un sujet qui
donne lieu à beaucoup de démagogie
souvent pour ne pas dire à du populisme
et d'ailleurs les élections européennes
on l'a vu déjà dans les déclarations du
Front national vont être l'occasion de
beaucoup de démagogie il faut faire les
choses avec sérieux avec lucidité mais
il faut vraiment qu'on réussisse enfin
l'intégration en France
si vous voulez bien travailler mercredi
à l'Assemblée nationale la ministre de
la Justice Christiane Taubira contrainte
de s'expliquer
c'est un petit peu version controversion
la ministre de la Justice Christiane
Taubira dément avoir voulu muter le
procureur général de Paris François
faletty comme l'indiquait auparavant le
Canard Enchaîné elle l'a dit avec force
lors des questions à l'Assemblée
nationale avec évidemment la droite qui
s'est engouffrée dans la brèche écouter
cet échange
concernant le procureur général de la
cour d'appel de Paris je note qu'il a
été invité à cet entretien qui est tout
à fait classique avec la direction de
mon cabinet par un appel le jeudi 23
janvier et si vous en voulez la preuve
en demandera une Fadette si tout cela
est confirmé je ne vois pas comment elle
peut rester mise la justice si c'est
confirmé faut pas oublier l'adresse de
la ministre de la Justice
d'abord ce n'est pas elle qui a reçu le
procureur général faletty c'est sa
directrice de cabinet que s'est-il dit
dans le bureau de la directrice de
cabinet monsieur Faletti a écrit un
courrier dans lequel il dit des choses
madame Taubira a donné son explication à
l'Assemblée nationale moi je ne peux pas
en dire plus sur cette affaire je pense
que en fait le vrai problème que pose
cette polémique c'est celui de
l'indépendance de la justice et du
statut du parquet cela fait 15 ans plus
de 15 ans maintenant que l'on discute de
la réforme du parquet j'étais ici à
l'Assemblée nationale le rapporteur de
la loi chancellerie parquet en 1998 sous
le gouvernement Jospin le gouvernement
Jospin a voulu réformer le parquet lui
donner enfin l'indépendance qui est
celle de tous les parquets des
démocraties
occidentales Jacques Chirac a entravé la
réforme on n'a pas pu aller au bout le
gouvernement de Jean-Marc Ayrault a
remis l'ouvrage sur le métier l'année
dernière le Sénat suffisante pour aller
voter la réforme du CSM donc on est à
nouveau en panne d'une grande réforme
attendue par tous les démocrates tous
les républicains et surtout tous les
magistrats du par il faut que la justice
le parquet en l'occurrence que la
justice soit indépendante qu'elle soit
perçue comme telle par les citoyens le
soupçon le soupçon ronge l'autorité
judiciaire ou plutôt le soupçon ronge la
confiance que les citoyens doivent avoir
dans l'autorité judiciaire il faut en
finir avec ce soupçon il faut réformer
le CSM la réforme est prête à être votée
je vais la droite au pied du mur la
droite fait une polémique assez
virulente sur l'affaire faletty si j'ose
dire mais que la droite met ses actes en
conformité avec ses propos gouvernements
doit représenter la loi je pense que le
gouvernement doit à nouveau présenter la
réforme du CSM au Parlement qu'on la
vote définitivement qu'on aille à
Versailles en congrès pour tourner la
page de cette de ce statut qui qui n'est
plus acceptable la France est condamnée
régulièrement par la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme et par le Conseil de
l'Europe parce qu'elle considère ces
deux instances que le parquet français
n'est pas indépendant il faut en finir
c'est un engagement de François Hollande
et je veux qu'il soit tenu le ministère
de la Justice nomme les procureurs il
faut que le ministère de la Justice
tout autre chose c'était une promesse de
campagne de François Hollande
l'assistance médicalisée pour terminer
sa vie dans la dignité pour le rappeler
au gouvernement le groupe écologiste au
Sénat à la déposé une proposition de loi
sur la fin de vie elle prévoit notamment
le suicide assisté Marie bremo
au Sénat quel que soit leur appartenance
politique les élus dressent presque tous
le même constat il y a une forte demande
de notre population de prendre une
position plus précise et en particulier
au moment où se produisent des des
événements comme celui de Monsieur de
Monsieur Vincent Lambert faire face aux
problèmes du mal mourir c'est l'objet de
la proposition de loi du groupe
écologiste qui autorise entre autres
l'aide au suicide une proposition qui
veut rassembler et qui trouve l'adhésion
de sénateur y compris d'autres groupes
nous souhaitons que ça soit une
proposition de loi qui ne soit pas
simplement les écologistes mais que
c'est l'ensemble des forces y compris
Centris y compris des gens de l'UMP qui
s'associent à cette demande puisque ça
dépasse les clivages politiques cette
proposition de loi sera débattue en
séance mais il n'y aura pas de vote
l'objectif passer la main au
gouvernement sur le sujet là il y a un
contexte évident qui n'est pas favorable
à avoir réellement un débat en séance
sur cette question je pense qu'il faut
voilà donner au gouvernement toute la
place qu'il a sur ce sujet là avec cette
proposition de loi les verres veulent
avant tout faire pression sur le
gouvernement un texte serait donc déjà
prêt si à l'avenir l'exécutif renonçait
à l'engagement 21 du candidat Hollande à
savoir l'assistance médicalisée pour
terminer sa vie dans la dignité on l'a
bien entendu faire pression sur le
gouvernement selon vous François
Hollande va-t-il tenir sa promesse de
campagne moi je pense qu'il va tenir sa
promesse il a réitéré son engagement
lors sa conférence de presse j'ai ici la
déclaration qu'il a faite il souhaite un
nouveau cadre légal pour que toute
personne majeure atteint d'une maladie
incurable et qu'une peut être apaisée
puisse demander dans des conditions
strictes une assistance médicalisée pour
terminer sa vie en dignité je pense
qu'il faut légiférer à nouveau
prudemment avec délicatesse ce sont des
sujets très compliqués qui font appel à
la part la plus intime de soi-même
euh c'est très difficile de faire des
lois générales sur des sujets aussi
aussi compliqué difficile délicat
douloureux il faut le faire même si la
loi Leonetti je m'empresse de le dire a
été une bonne loi c'était une grande
avancée moi j'ai beaucoup d'estime pour
Jean léoetti il a fait il a fait une loi
courageuse qui n'était pas d'ailleurs
très appréciée par dans son propre camp
il y a eu beaucoup de mal à l'époque à
l'UMP avec avec cette loi de de 2005
cette loi a mis fin à l'acharnement
thérapeutique elle a permis le
développement des soins palliatifs il
faut aller sans doute plus loin et plus
suffisante elle n'est plus suffisante il
faut compléter l'aloeimétie d'ailleurs
Jean Leonetti a proposé lui-même et en
2013 une nouvelle loi sur la sédation
qui permet un peu plus loin que que la
loi de 2005 il faut légiférer donc mais
avec le respect de chaque opinion c'est
un peu comme sur la loi family la
procréation médicalement assistée il ne
faut pas jeter la nathème sur ceux qui
ne pensent pas comme vous faut être
respectueux de toutes les sensibilités
des craintes là dans la population sur
sur ce genre de texte je pense que ce
sujet est plus consensuel que celui qui
touche à la procréation médicalement
assistée même si d'ailleurs sur la PMA
j'ai vu que les sondages montrent qu'une
majorité de Français et favorable mais
en façon des sujets compliqués
il y a aussi une frange de la population
qui est con mais toutes les familles ou
presque sont aujourd'hui concernées par
des questions de fin de vie il faut
aussi envisager de développer les
directives anticipées que pourraient
donner chaque citoyen chaque homme
chaque femme avant de mourir et même
longtemps avant de mourir qu'il puisse
préparer sa mort et aller chez le
notaire pour pourquoi pas dire voilà
comment je souhaite que ça se passe si
un jour je ne suis plus conscient et que
je suis dans une dans une situation de
fin de vie douloureuse donc il y a
beaucoup de solutions qui ne sont pas
simples je le répète à mettre en oeuvre
ce qui est le plus difficile de faire
une loi générale avec des termes
juridiques sur des sujets aussi intimes
mais je pense que sans passion avec
beaucoup de de modération et de respect
des opinions de toutes les opinions on
peut avancer la France s'achemine donc
vers l'autorisation du suicide assisté
maintenant je n'aime pas du tout cette
expression le mot suicide est beaucoup
trop fort et il n'est pas à mon avis
représentatif de ce que nous voulons
faire c'est ce que réclame notamment un
certain nombre de polyhandicapés
il faut les aider à mourir dans la
dignité selon leur volonté mais je
n'aime pas qu'on parle de suicide je
préfère un autre mot en ce moment vous
l'avez suivi Vincent Lambert
sa famille est déchirée les médecins
l'épousent et le neveu on saisit le
Conseil d'État pour l'autoriser à mourir
la décision était renvoyée la semaine
prochaine par une édition collégiale du
Conseil d'État c'est une première qui
doit avoir le dernier mot c'est le
médecin ou c'est le juge cette histoire
est éminemment très très difficile c'est
évidemment
un conseiller élargi c'est d'ailleurs
dans les propositions de loi qui qui
sont en discussion aujourd'hui un
conseiller élargi non seulement le corps
médical mais la famille donc ce
conseiller l'argile aux proches de celui
qui qui va mourir et puis si il n'y a
pas de possibilité de faire autrement le
juge bien sûr mais si on peut évidemment
éviter le recours au juge et faire en
sorte que le corps médical et la famille
trouve un accord c'est beaucoup mieux
évidemment une formation que les jeunes
qui se prononcera donc la semaine
prochaine d'État je vous propose de
passer au jeudi au Sénat Serge
d'assauffet à nouveau parler de lui
le Sénat qui se retrouve une nouvelle
fois au pied du mur une nouvelle demande
de lever d'immunité a été demandé au
Sénat pour Serge Dassault ce sénateur
évidemment devra se prononcer les Sénas
devra se prononcer la semaine prochaine
le bureau devra s'exprimer la semaine
prochaine eu égard à l'institution
est-ce que c'est une tâche ou pas
écouter Jean-Pierre Bel le président du
Sénat ça nécessite si j'ai bien compris
quelques quelques jours pour l'instant
dans le naturellement nous avons rien
reçu certains sont mieux informés que
moi mais naturellement dès que nous
serons saisis et bien nous réagirons et
nous réunirons le bureau pour rencontre
la levée d'humidité pour évidemment il
faut que la justice puisse faire son
travail et pour la levée d'immunité
parlementaire à main levée à main levée
bien sûr que l'on sache qui vote quoi ce
qui s'est passé l'autre jour et qu'à la
miteux pour le Sénat le Sénat n'a pas
toujours une bonne image ce qui est
d'ailleurs très injuste parce que c'est
une maison on travaille beaucoup avec
beaucoup de sérieux on va en profondeur
dans les sujets qui nous sont soumis je
peux en parler en connaissance la cause
compare avec l'Assemblée nationale à
l'Assemblée en travaillant aussi bien
sûr on est plus dans dans l'écume des
jours dans les le médiatiques ce qui
fait ce qui fait la une des médias dans
les petites phrases les quatre colonnes
au Sénat c'est plus calme c'est beaucoup
plus sérieux et je travaille beaucoup en
commission des affaires étrangères donc
le Sénat est une belle maison où on fait
un très bon travail et il faut de temps
en temps qu'il y ait et là ce genre
d'incident comme là la non levée du
musée parlementaire de Serge Dassault
pour que à nouveau le Sénat est une
mauvaise image dans le pignon c'est très
injuste pour le Sénat donc il faut
évidemment qu'on change la procédure
c'est ce qu'a dit Jean-Pierre Bel vote à
main levée et moi je souhaite que la
limiter parlementaire de Serge Dassault
soit levé non pas parce que j'en veux à
Serge la chose je ne le connais pas mais
pour que la justice puisse faire son
travail
on élargit un tout petit peu est-ce que
l'immunité parlementaire encore un sens
aujourd'hui non je suis pour ces
suppression je pense que cette
c'est une protection juridique d'un
autre âge qui à l'époque avait sa
justification lorsqu'elle a été créée
l'immunité parenthèse il s'agissait de
protéger les parlementaires contre une
justice aux ordres aux ordres du pouvoir
impérial sous Napoléon III enfin du
pouvoir tout court sous les républiques
suivantes parce qu'on craignait souvent
un juste titre que le pouvoir manipulant
la justice puisse aller embêter entre
guillemets tel ou telle parlementaire
qui n'était pas assez docile donc pour
protéger les parlementaires contre le
méchant pouvoir exécutif et le pouvoir
judiciaire qui lui était très soumis il
fallait cette immunité parlementaire
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus du tout le cas
il faut que l'immunité parlementaire
disparaisse les députés les sénateurs
sont des citoyens comme les autres si la
justice leur demande des comptes ils
doivent rendre des comptes conscient que
évidemment dans tous les cas on n'est
pas d'accord avec vous
je ne sais pas on en a pas tellement
parlé encore de cette suppression de
limiter parlementaire
de l'opposition de droite évidemment ils
disent tous la même chose que vous donc
on n'est pas prêt d'y arriver moi je ne
sais pas il y a des réformes comme ça
dont on pense qu'elles sont impossibles
et puis finalement ils arrivent moi je
suis prêt à essayer de convaincre mes
collègues
le plus de l'hebdo cette semaine revient
sur le parcours de Valéry Giscard
d'Estaing l'impossible retour après sa
défaite à la présidentielle
Giscard l'impossible retour c'est le
titre du documentaire de Laurent lutteau
où comment l'ancien président de la
République a tenté de revenir sur le
devant de la scène politique après son
échec il retrace la carrière de l'animal
politique agate picastin je souhaite que
la providence veille sur la France
pour son bonheur
pour son bien et pour ça grandeur
au revoir avec cette phrase qui restera
célèbre Valéry Giscard d'estain vit sa
première défaite une défaite qu'il va
devoir assumer pendant le reste de sa
carrière ce documentaire retrace
l'impossible au retour de celui qui
demeure le plus jeune chef d'État élu
sous la 5e République à ceux qui disent
qu'il repart de zéro monsieur Giscard
d'Estaing répond non je reviens tout
simplement l'Auvergne l'Europe l'appétit
politique de l'ex-président et dévorant
mais jamais rassasié 7 ans a exercé le
pouvoir et 30 ans à chercher à le
retrouver l'histoire de Giscard est
avant tout celle d'un animal politique
qui comprend mal les hommes mais a su
saisir les évolutions de son temps sa
rupture ça son échec inaugure une
période qui sera celle des grands
manipulateurs de courant d'opinion que
sont Mitterrand Chirac ou Sarkozy
trahison échec couba Valéry Giscard
d'Estaing ne renoncera pourtant jamais à
l'appel du pouvoir mais comment revenir
quand on a été en haut de l'affiche la
question demeure je pense qu'un ancien
président de la République peut avoir un
avenir dans la République non pas par
conquête mais par circonstance parce que
la politique c'est aussi une question de
bon timing un dilemme que semble bien
avoir saisi un certain Nicolas Sarkozy
André valligny après la défaite à son
corps possible de reconquérir le pouvoir
oui en politique tout est possible tout
dépend des circonstances c'est ce que
disait le documentaire à l'instant ces
images m'ont rajeuni
jusqu'à destin aurait pu revenir
il s'est trouvé qu'il a trouvé Raymond
Barre sur sa route puis Édouard Balladur
les circonstances en politique tout est
possible et faire des projections à plus
de trois mois ça ne sert à rien donc je
ne sais pas ce que Nicolas Sarkozy verra
en 2017 je suis sûr qu'il a envie d'être
candidat est-ce qu'elle pourra l'être
non mais sur l'exemple Giscard
d'estampes il reste encore un petit
moment parce que c'est quand même aussi
quelque chose qui se poursuit en
politique aujourd'hui on prend toujours
l'exemple de Valéry Giscard d'Estaing
est-ce que c'est le mauvais exemple
non c'est pas le mauvais ou le bon
exemple c'est l'exemple de quelqu'un qui
n'a pas pu revenir mais il y a d'autres
exemples poincarés par exemple a été
prise en la République et il a
recommencé sa carrière politique en
étant élu conseiller général puis
sénateur et il a été ensuite deux fois
président du conseil donc c'est en
politique tout est toujours positionnez
pas mort physiquement on n'est pas mort
politiquement c'est aussi une question
de personnalité parce qu'on le voit si
on parle un peu plus de 2017 la
personnalité d'un président de la
République fait aussi beaucoup savoir
s'il peut revenir ou pas si vous prenez
l'exemple de Nicolas Sarkozy qui envoie
des cartes postales semaines après
semaine qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
vous je pense que Nicolas Sarkozy a
combativité
qu'il faut pour vouloir revenir en
politique au premier plan et candidats
d'après c'est évident qu'il a envie
d'être candidat circonstances tout à
l'heure il suffit que les circonstances
ne soient pas bonnes pour qu'il ne
puissent bien
évidemment et puis et puis moi je crois
beaucoup que le pacte de responsabilité
va marcher et que François Hollande aura
réussi son pari qu'il sera à nouveau
candidat et réélu ce que je veux dire
sur le pacte de responsabilité c'est
qu'il faut accélérer le processus moi je
trouve que tout ça prend trop de temps
j'ai vu que le patronat les syndicats se
rencontrent la semaine prochaine le
gouvernement
oui non parce que Sarkozy Giscard c'est
bien mais moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
Hollande et la réussite de sa politique
et il faut absolument accélérer le
processus moi je souhaite évidemment que
le Parlement soit saisi au printemps ça
va être le cas et que tout ça se mettre
en oeuvre très vite il faudrait qu'à la
rentrée à la rentrée de septembre 2014
le pacte soit effectif que les charges
sociales baissent et que le patronat
embauche on peut pas attendre encore un
an ou deux il y a urgent
urgence à faire en sorte que la France
est bien se réveille
économiquement que le patronat les
syndicat Joul jeu dans les branches
aussi dans les régions partout il faut
mobiliser tout le pays autour de ce pack
François Hollande a pris un risque
considérable par rapport à son électorat
il faut vraiment l'aider à réussir parce
que c'est Hollande parce que c'est la
France et justement
vous vous l'avez vous le connaissez bien
vous étiez très proche au moment où il
était un peu à traverser du désert le
monsieur 3 à l'époque aujourd'hui vous
reconnaissez le François Hollande ou pas
en plus que jamais oui avec cette
volonté inflexible de réussir le mandat
mal à sang-froid c'est un animal à
sang-froid je ne sais pas ce que ça veut
dire je pense qu'il a il a des qualités
effectivement de comment dire de
solidité intérieure c'est un roc à
l'intérieur
on dit vraiment barque c'était un esprit
carré dans un corps rond François
Hollande
comme ça une apparence assez sympathique
il est sympathique d'ailleurs il est
très sympathique il a un abord très
facile mais à l'intérieur c'est un rock
il est inflexible quand il décide
quelque chose il s'y tient là il a
décidé de prendre un risque considérable
politiquement parce que c'était pas
évident de faire passer le pack de
compétitivité notamment à gauche à la
gauche de la gauche même dans le PS
seulement c'était la seule solution
c'était la seule solution pour sortir la
France de l'ornière et éviter à la
France qu'elle soit frappée de déclin
économique donc il faut l'aider tout le
monde personnalité il a cette
point cette hagne en lieu ou pas il a de
la personnalité
oui ça je peux vous dire que nous qui
connaissons bien les Hollandais
historiques comme vous dites ça nous
fait un peu rire quand on entend qu'il
n'aurait pas assez d'autorité ou de
personnalité parce que nous qui
connaissons bien depuis quelques jours
tout le temps d'abord on devient on ne
devient pas président de la République
si on n'a pas d'autorité ou de
personnalité pardonnez-moi mais sous la
5e République au suffrage universel pour
arriver à l'Elysée il faut de l'autorité
de la personnalité il n'y a que ceux qui
ne le connaissent pas qui disent qu'il
manque d'autorité de personnalité il est
parfois très dur et il a raison de
l'être avec ses amis et ses
collaborateurs il sait ce qu'il veut et
il sait comment y arriver seulement pour
ça il faut mobiliser le pays c'est ce
que je m'emploie à faire avec d'autres
si on revient justement sur le pacte de
responsabilité de compétitivité est-ce
que justement l'une des difficultés de
François Hollande ce n'est pas la durée
du quinquennat aujourd'hui trop court
trop court
c'est vrai c'est très court
de temps c'est 18 premiers mois on peut
toujours dire ça moi je regarde pas le
passé je regarde aujourd'hui il y a un
pacte il y a des mesures qui ont été
annoncées le gouvernement prend des
risques il faut y aller maintenant ne
regardons pas ce qui avait fait en plus
des choses ont été faites le pacte de
compétitivité le Crédit Impôt
compétitivité en octobre 2013 c'était
déjà une avancée considérable au
2012-2012 octobre 2012 donc il y avait
eu des choses de fait on a approfondi on
accélère on passe à la vitesse
supérieure il faut maintenant être soudé
derrière le gouvernement pour réussir
mais ça j'ai passé merci beaucoup André
Vallini d'avoir participé à notre
émission on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine à la semaine prochaine bonne
semaine
en mai 1996 les 7 moines français de
tibéry en Algérie sont sauvagement
assassinés
les islamistes
des services algériens mais aujourd'hui
de nouveaux éléments viennent remettre
en cause cette thèse officielle il y
avait l'affirmation selon laquelle les
militaires algériens là au niveau de
l'assassinat au niveau de la mort des
moines se trouvait impliqué dans
l'affaire des moines de tibéry
globale
Algérie qui a tué les moines français
demain à 15h15 sur Public Sénat